the artist Christian Talia vini is
putting the finishing touches on this
exhibition at the camera works gallery
in Berlin
sometimes it takes a month to prepare a
photo costumes props and scenery are all
here and they all have to be in the
right place I don't consider myself a
photographer who simply captures moments
of everyday life I'm a craftsman who
uses the medium of photography to
transform my ideas into pictures I'm
also a craftsman because I want to
portray what's going on behind the
scenes that's really important to me
Tania Venus series yr extraordinaire was
inspired by the French writers Rivera
and his series of books by the same name
but the characters are products of the
artists imagination in fact he made a
conscious decision not to read valens
novels but he did conduct extensive
research so everything is as realistic
as possible I wanted to use this bizarre
instrument the tapa phone in my
photographs which means so I came up
with the idea of having a researcher use
one tapa phones were originally used to
eavesdrop on the enemy in wartime
taia vini calls his pictures designed
narratives they're much more than just
photographs particularly when you
consider all the work he did to get them
ready in fact it took him about two
years to prepare these 28 photographs
it's absolutely crazy that someone would
spend so much time on one project it's
really impressive in this day and age I
think it's great that he sees time as a
valuable commodity and that he takes the
necessary time to create a work like
this Talya beanie as a designer and
architect by training he crafts his
works at his studio in Lugano he
designed the costumes but left the
manufacturing to the professionals he
hires models who look exactly like the
images of the characters he has in mind
this photo series is called 1503 it
resembles 16th century portraits dama de
tournay features characters wearing 50
style clothes made from cardboard and
karate is a series about the characters
that appear on playing cards some ok
let's see oh nice on temporary home for
everyone I get my ideas rather suddenly
it's not a gradual or slow-moving
process they just turn up suddenly like
when I'm driving or taking a shower
Talia V news pictures are produced in
limited editions prices start at 4800
euros yrx probably never is his most
complex project yet it's been 2 or 3
years since I started this project still
I really don't feel like taking a break
at this point but I will carefully
consider what to do next all I can say
is that it will definitely be different
from this one
Kilis ah but for now christian talia
vini is still putting the finishing
touches on his current project his yr
extraordinaire will be on display in
berlin until the end of February